bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france des libanais
mobilisés par milliers dans les rues de
la capitale
vengeance jusqu'à la chute du régime
c'est ce que scandent des manifestants
amassés place des martyrs ce drame
semble avoir été le coup de grâce mais
aussi un catalyseur pour les libanais
peut-on dire que ça n'a fait que
renforcer leur détermination dans le
rejet de toute la classe politique
on va voir
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
a accéléré une prise déjà extrêmement
profonde des systèmes politiques
financiers et économiques du pays
si les dirigeants jouer la montre
auparavant avant cette sodam cinéma
innommable qui a frappé la ville de
beyrouth et bien le temps est encore
plus court maintenant puisque ce drame
appelle de nouvelles de nouveaux besoins
financiers immédiats qu'ils viennent
s'ajouter aux besoins et la
détérioration de la situation précédente
avec cette catastrophe un port de
beyrouth il ya aussi la crise économique
politique et sanitaire jusqu'où les
libanais qui semble ne plus rien avoir à
perdre sont ils prêts à aller selon vous
je pense que la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui est un des moments où on
va essayer de mesurer à cette
détermination et il est clair que la
colère est très élevé total je puis dire
il ya beaucoup de manifestants dans les
rues
mais comme vous pouvez sans doute le
voir vous même
il n'y a pas d'unité ou deux plateformes
unifiante pour cette colère il ya
plusieurs manières de l'exprimer avec
des slogans différents et puis des
initiatives différente puisque comme
vous l'avez vous même dit certains
manifestants essaye de bon d'entrer au
parlement qui lui même est protégé par
un mur et des forces sécurité
extrêmement importante à signaler que
d'après certaines de nos informations
certains manifestants sont entrées dans
le parlement hier soir pendant la nuit
et ont provoqué des combats avec des
forces de sécurité et ont été expulsés
donc il ya quelque part un agenda
d'occupation du parlement qui serait une
initiative compréhensible dans le cadre
de la colère ambiante qui règne dans la
ville le changement de système politique
est il la seule solution selon vous il
n'ya pas de raccourcir à cette affaire
le dame est tellement profond que on ne
peut plus faire des réparations par
siècle
effectivement seuls changements
drastiques fondamentale du système
politique économique peuvent mener à une
solution de survie pour le pays
nous sommes dans une situation de survie
du pays
ce n'est plus une question de
négociation là ne pas trouver une voie
de sortie de la crise aujourd'hui veut
dire que le pays se dirige vers une
faillite totale avec des drames humains
donc il ya des besoins humains à court
terme mais ils ne peuvent pas être
comment dirais-je solide solidement
réparer s'il n'y a pas de plan à moyen
et long terme ce plan-là existait avant
le drame
ce besoin aussi existé avant le drame il
n'en est que beaucoup plus urgent
aujourd'hui ce que vous attendez
beaucoup de l'aide internationale alors
l'international pour essayer de remettre
le pays sur pied de remettre les
habitants de beyrouth sur pied
absolument cruciale aujourd'hui le
problème c'est d'organiser l'arrivée de
cette aide est d'organiser l'arrivée des
flux financier qui finance cette aide
pour l'état de manière à ce qu'il ne
tombe pas dans les mains de ceux qui de
n'importe qui si je puis dire
il ya certaines ong qui essaient de
s'organiser pour assurer une
transparence et efficacité pour ces flux
et il est évident que les donateurs
eux-mêmes cherche
des solutions pour faire arriver leurs
flux d'une manière efficace parce qu'eux
aussi sont extrêmement méfiant il faut
effectivement essayé de résoudre cette
équation très très vite à court terme
parce qu'elle est la condition du succès
de l'aide accordée par fondre il n'y a
pas d' aide internationale possible pour
que le liban puisse retrouver un système
politique et financier et économique
surtout viable pour tous ses citoyens
ce ne sont que les libanais qui peuvent
trouver cette voie certains encore au
liban cherche désespérément des alliés
extérieurs
il n'y a pas de solution externe il n'y
aura qu'une solution interne fait les
construite par les libanais eux-mêmes et
elle commence par un diagnostic réel de
la situation sur tout sur place et un
plan économique et social qui montre que
les libanais sont prêts à être
solidaires entre eux et non pas
solidaires avec leurs commanditaires
étrangers
il faut que les libanais trou d'une
formule de solidarité entre eux mêmes et
ça c'est l'enjeu de toute transition
politique qui économie merci beaucoup
pour cet éclairage la sem ce neige pour
se toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en finance ses
professeurs associés d'économie à
sciences po merci beaucoup